[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار
ملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
اسرائيل تحضر العالم صنع القرار سيتغير
عالميا اذا امتلكت ايران سلاح نوويه
دعاه التطرف الى الواجهه مجددا متطرفون في
المنطقه يعلنون تاييد قرار طالبان منع
تدريس الفتيات
يومان تفصل احياء الرياض عن رحله التشجير
اكثر من سبعه ملايين الشجره ضمن مشروع
الرياض الخضراء
ومن ملفاتنا التي نناقشها معكم في الرابعه
ايضا
انجازه 45% من اعمال مطار جازان الجديد
طاقه استيعابيه تتجاوز ثلاثه ملايين مسافر
سنويا
موجه امطار على سواحل عمان والامارات
الموعد السنوي
لثلوج تبوك يتجدد
حياكم الله اكل رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي
ابيفكو خافي ان السلاح النووي الايراني
يظل اكبر تهديدا محتمل مشيرا الى ان عمليه
صنع القرار ستتغير عالميا اذا امتلكت
ايران هذا السلاح وكشف كوخافي ان اسرائيل
احبطت مخططا ايرانيه لنشر مئات الصواريخ
في سوريا مشيرا الى ان لدى تل ابيب المزيد
مما يجب ان تفعله بشان الوجود الايراني في
سوريا
ستتغير عمليه صنع القرار بالكامل لجميع
اللاعبين في العالم تماما بمجرد ان تمتلك
ايران سلاحا نوويا للاغراض العسكريا لقد
تحسن مستوى استعداد ايران لكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي جاهز لاي اوامر ضد نووي ايران
وسيلتزم بالمهام الموكله اليه وقمنا
بالفعل باحباط مخطط ايران لنشر مئات
الصواريخ في سوريا ولدينا المزيد مما
سنفعله
هذا وشدد رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي على
ضروره ان يشمل التصدي لايران كله كائها
وانشطه وانشطتها في الشرق الاوسط ضمن رؤيه
شامله الى جانب الملف النووي مشيرا الى ان
ايران كتفت من انشطتها المزعزعه للاستقرار
في السنوات الاخيره
تتجاوز الحدود الجغرافيه للبلد المسمى
ايران اولا وقبل كل شيء هو التهديد
المحتمل للقدره النوويه العسكريه وبجانبها
هناك قضيه ثاني رئيسيه اخرى
جميع انشطه الوكلاء الايرانيين في جميع
انحاء الشرق الاوسط وما وراءه في افريقيا
واماكن اخرى الى جانب القوات العسكريه
والبنيه التحتيه الايرانيه في لبنان
وسوريا التحركات الايرانيه حمله متعدده
الابعاد جويه وبحريه وبريه وسبرانيه في
المنطقه كلها من يظن ان هذه الحمله تجري
فقط على سوريا فهو مخطئ انها تحتضن الشرق
الاوسط باكملها على مستويات مختلفه وهي
حمله تم تكثيفها في السنوات الاخيره التحق
بينا من القاهره الدكتور عماد جاد مستشار
مركز الاهرام للدراسات دكتور عماد مرحبا
بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض ما
الجديد الذي حمله رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي
في هذه التصريحات ليست المره الاولى التي
تهدد فيها اسرائيل باستهداف منشات نوويه
ايرانيه
تحذر كذلك من الانشطه المزعزيعه لايران في
المنطقه فما الجديد برايك
الجديد هو النظره الاسرائيليه الشامله
للخطر الايراني ليس فقط امتلاك البرنامج
النووي وهو الاكثر خطوره والذي تعهدت
اسرائيل اكثر من مره
بمقاومته بكل الطرق الممكنه وحولت مع
الادارات الامريكيه المختلفه ودخلت في
خلاف شديد مع الرئيس الامريكي الحالي
ايضا ايران اسرائيل بدات تتحدث عن الانشطه
الايرانيه ككل الانشطه المزعزيعه
للاستقرار عبر بعتها في المنطقه اي انها
تنظر يعني زياده قدرات الحسين في مدخل
الجنوبي للبحر الاحمر على انه تهديد تنظر
للتواجد الايراني في سوريا والعراق على
انه تهديد في لبنان ايضا على انه تهديده
وبالتالي اسرائيل تمتلك رؤيه شامله لطبيعه
الخطر الايراني وترى همم ان امتلاك ايران
لبرنامج نووي او او سلاح نووي
فيغير طبيعه المنطقه بالكامل وربما يتوافق
ذلك مع بعض التصريحات الخاصه بدول المنطقه
التي تقول وسبق وذكرت ان اا اسمح لي ايران
بامتلك سلاح نووي قد يغير مواقف همم بعض
القوه الاقليميه الرئيسيه وهذا ما اردت ان
اسال عن الدكتور عماد يعني رئيس الاركان
يقول بان ايران اذا امتلكت سلاحا نويا همم
فان اللعبه عالميه ستتغير ما الذي يقصده
بان عمليه صنع القرار ستتغير على كل
المستويات
يعني هو يقصد بالاساس ان في حال امتلاك
ايران لسلاح نووي وهي قريبه منه بعد وصول
التخصيب ل 60% وربما اكثر من ذلك
يقول باننا لا نستطيع يعني اذا كانت هناك
معارك منع الانتشار النووي والدول دول
المنطقه الرئيسيه والتي تشعر بخطر من
السلاح النووي الايراني هذه الدول اذا
كانت تلتزم بمعاهده منع الانتشار النووي
في تلك الحاله اذا امتلك ايران سلاحا فان
هذه الدول قدم تتغير مواقفه بالفعل يمكن
ان تتغير مواقفها اتجاه امتلاكس سلاح
النواب بالتالي مساله منع الانتشار النووي
الكبرى منها سوف يتغير ولا يمكن لي الدول
الكبرى التي تكافح من اجل منع الانتشار
النووي ام تمنع دول المنطقه من امتلاك
سلاح موازن للسلاح النووي الايطالي لان
ايران دوله مهدده
الدكتور عماد اليوم ومع قدوم وع اتمنى
اتمنى اخرى لرئاسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
برايك هل ستتغير معه مدام جديه فاعليه
الجيش الاسرائيلي في ان يستهدف هذه
المنشات النوويه او ربما حتى يستهدف
الاذرعه الايرانيه في المنطقه ليس سوريا
في حسب كما ذكر رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي
وما هو الخط الاحمر الذي لا تقبل اسرائيل
الى المساس به الدكتور عماد يعني هو طبعا
اسرائيل بذلك كبيرا في محاصره ازرع ايران
عبر استهداف امدادات السلاح ومواقع مركز
همم يعني القوات التابعه لايران وحزب الله
في سوريا وكنا نشاهد ربما بمعدل يومي هذا
الامر هو محاوله همم
لملاحقه او تصدي لازرع ايران الجديد معنا
اكثر جديه همم
ما يمثله البرنامج النووي الايراني ايضا
لديه قد ضخمه في التعامل مع الاداره
الامريكيه همم لا يتعامل معها من خلال همم
الاستماع فقط ولكن يطرح رؤيهه الخط الاحمر
هو ان تقترب ايران من امتلاك السلاح
النووي
واعتقد انه بعد ان كلف بتشكيل الحكومه همم
خرجت يعني تصريحات محدده من رئاسه الاركان
الاسرائيليه التي يتم رئيس الاركان الجديد
يقول بان لدينا ثلاث خطط بديله في التعامل
مع البرنامج النووي الايراني واننا سنقوم
بمنع ايران من امتلاك السلاح النووي مهما
كان سواء بالتعاون مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او من خلال
تحرك اسرائيلي منفرد لان اسرائيل وان
نتنيه تحديدا كان يقول ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بعيده الاميره يعني
دكتور في همم نحن اليوم نعيش في في في
حاله ربما من تعثر يعني اكيد
للمفاوضات النوويه مع ايران وربما احد
المسؤولين الاوروبيين قال بان المفاوضات
قد انتهت هكذا وص في وقت سابقا وقريب مع
همم
تعثر هذا الملف النووي تعثر الوصول
الاتفاق النووي هل يمكن ان تقوم اسرائيل
باي عمل منفرد دون الرجوع لدول اا الدول
الكبرى الدول الاتفاق النووي مع اسرائيل
وانت مع ايران عفوا وان تقوم بعمل عسكري
همم منفرد ضد ايران لاستهداف منشاه نوويه
شوف حضرتك يعني نعلم تماما ان اجهزه
الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه المختلفه
بانواعها المختلفه من مدنيه وعسكريه لديها
همم معلومات قدره مكثفه وكبيره للغايه على
الوصول الى قلبي ايران وعلى القيام
بعمليات في مدن ايران المختلفه وعمليات
همم عاليه من ناحيه الدقه التكنولوجيه
لاسيما في عمليه القيالات وتعقيل البرنامج
النووي وما الى ذلك همم اتصور انا همم
الرؤيه الاسرائيليه لا ده نتنياهو تحديد
همم اكثر من طابقين هو همم انه في حال
اقتراب ايران من امتلاء سلاح نووي ذلك
سيؤثر خطرا دائما على الوجود الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي في هذه الاله هي تقول ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بعيده الاف
الاميره همم مثلها مثل البعد عن كوريا
الشماليه الذي يشعر بخطر كوريا الشماليه
لكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان وبالتالي
اسرائيل هي التي تشعر همم ودور المنطقه
تشعر بخطر اليك ايران للسلاح النو ثاني
يمكن لاسرائيل بالفعل في حال همم ان
ايراتوي سوف تتحرك منفردا لانه دفاعا عن
امنيه القومي ووجودها همم بشكل رائع اشكرك
جزيلا شكرا من القاهره الدكتور عماد جاد
مستشار مركز الاهرام للدراسات الرابعه
مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
جوله ثالثه في اكبر محميه للسلاحف او في
ثالث اكبر محميه للسلاحف في العالم تحت
ظنها ولايه اصول بسلطنه عمان
حياكم الله من جديد في السعوديه اعلن
برنامج الرياضه الخضراء احد مشاريع الرياض
الاربعه الكبرى عن بدء اعمال تنفيذي تشجير
الاحياء السكنيه حيث يستهدف البرنامج
تسجيل اكثر من 120 حيا سكنيا تشمل تنفيذ
حدائق وتشجير الشوارع الداخليه والتنفيذ
الارصفه المشجره وممرات للمشاه وغيرها
وفقا للبرنامج فان البدايه ستكون من خلال
حي العزيزيه الذي ستبدا اعمال الخميس
المقبل حيث سيشهد زراعه اكثر من 600 الف
شجره وشجيره
[موسيقى]
قرار صادم لكنه متوقع قد تكونوا اقرب
الجمل التي تصف قرار حركه طالبان بمنع
دراسه الفتيات في الجامعه هذا القرار حرك
الكثير من المياه الراكده حول الصراع
الازلي بين المعتدلين والمتشددين في ظل
ردود فعل دوليه واسعه تستنكره القرار وقد
تحدد مستقبل العلاقات الدوليه مع حكومه
طالبان
قرار حضر حركه طالبان التعليم الجامعي
للنساء في افغانستان الى اجل غير مسمى
وبالرغم من ردود الفعل الدوليه المتواليه
التي استنكرت هذه الخطوه معتبره اياها
تضييقا على حريه النساء ومنعا لحقهن
الاساسي في التعليم وازدياد الضغوط
المطالبه بالتراجع عنه الا ان هناك ايادي
تصفق مؤيده لهذا القمع وتطل بين 2000
والاخرى لتشعر فتيل التشدد وتؤجج الصراع
الازليه بين المعتدلين والمتشددين قرروا
طالبان بحظر تعليم النساء لم يحظى بتاييد
اي مؤسسه دينيه او جهه دوليه كونه اعتبر
انتهاكا صريحا للقيم الانسانيه الدوليه
هيئه كبار العلماء السعوديه دعا الطالبان
الى التراجع عن قرارها بمنع الطالبات من
التعليم الجامعي لافته الى اهميه الاستماع
الى ما يقضي به الدين الاسلامي من تمكين
المراه من التعلم اما الازهر فقد عبر عن
كون القرار يشكل صدمه لانتهاكه مبادئ
الاسلام وتناقضه مع الشريعه الاسلاميه
التي تدعو لطلب العلم للنساء والرجال على
حد سواء الامين العام لرابطه العالم
الاسلامي ورئيس هيئه العلماء المسلمين
الدكتور محمد العيسى اكد بان هذا القرار
ام مخالف لاجماع علماء الامه الاسلاميه
بمختلف مذاهبهم وطوائفهم داعيا طالبان الى
التراجع عنه ومعاربا عن تضامنه التام مع
الفتيات والنساء الافغانيات في هذه القضيه
المرتبطه بشكل مباشر بمستقبل المراه في
افغانستان رن الشيخ العربيه
[موسيقى]
ثالث اكبر محميه للسلاحف في العالم تمتاز
وشواطئ ولايه صور بانواع عديده لهذه
السلاح هيئه البيئه العمانيه لتاسيس فريق
تطوعي لحمايه ومراقبه والاستاذه السلاحف
ومحاوله الحفاظ عليها ايضا من تهديد
الانقراض الزميل عبد الرحمن العصيمي مع
التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
تعد محميه السلاحف في راس الحد بولايه
الصور واحده من اهم المعالم السياحيه
المميزه في سلطنه عمان وتحتل مساحه 120
كيلو متر مربعا من اراضي ساحليه وعلى
امتداد الساحل الذي يبلغ طوله حوالي 40
كيلو مترا وتضم هذه المحميه اكثر من
20,000 سلحفاه لانواع مختلفه لذلك اطلقت
هيئه البيئه العمانيه برنامج ترتر
الكوماندوز لحمايه ومراقبتي السلاحف
البحريه
لهذه الثروه الطبيعيه اللي هي السلاحف
البحريه لان من اصل سبعه انواع سلاحف
بحريه في العالم سلطنه عمان تزورها خمسه
انواع فهذا يعني يجعل سلطنه عمان من اهم
ثلاث مواقع في العالم همم للسلاحف هذا
البرنامج يسعى الى حمايه هذه السلاحف من
خلال رفع مستوى الوعي المجتمعيه
كثير سلوك الافراد تجاه هذه الكائنات من
اهداف برنامج تارت الكوماندس همم هي توعيه
المجتمع خاصه المجتمع المحلي باهميه
السلاحف البحريه لانها كونها انها ثروه
طبيعيه تسخر فيها سلطنه عمان كذلك همم
تشجيع فئه الشباب على التطوع البيئي همم
بنظافه الشواطئ من اهداف الحمله والشباب
متطاوعين الاشاركونا يقوم همم تنظيف
ايضا الى تشجيعي فئه الشباب على التطوع
البيئي وذلك من خلال مشاركه المئات من
المتطوعين في البرامج المتنوعه لحمايه
السلاحف التي اصبحت مهدده بالانقراض بسبب
مخلفات البلاستيك على الشواطئ والتلوث
البيئي عبد الرحمن العصيمي من ولايه الصور
العربيه
عوده مره اخرى الى
الملف الذي كنا ناقشناه قبل قليل
واستعراضنا فيما يتعلق بقرار طالبان منع
الفتيات من الدراسه وكذلك ايضا منحتها
النساء من العمل في الجهات غير الحكوميه
والغاثيه في افغانستان
فهد مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض بدايه
ملف مانع الفتيات من الدراسه وكذلك من
العمل في المنظمات الحكوميه وغيرها برايك
طبعا جمله التايد في تغريدات قبل قليل هل
عاده تذكر طالبان هذه الايتلوجيه العوده
للمربع الاول في ما يخص اختطاف الاعتدال
الوسطيه حقوق النساء حقوق الانسان كذلك
بطبيعه الحال اللي انا عندي نظريه مؤمن
فيها منذ زمن بعيد عن
حركاتها الاسلام السياسي والحركات المسلحه
لن تنتهي بوقت قريب وانما لديها امتدادها
ولديها نفوذها ولديها عملها ولديها ايضا
ايديولوجيه التي تعمل تحت الارض وليس شرطا
ان تكون فوق الارض سواء فوق في السعوديه
او غير السعوديه او في لبنان او في العراق
او في الخليج وفي الشرق الاوسط وفي مصر او
في طالبان يعني كلها نظريات مستمره وممتده
وانما قد تعمل فوق الارض وقد تعمل تحت
الارض وانما طالبان لديها بعد بعد
الانسحاب الامريكي من من
افغانستان اصبح هناك لديها نفود شرس وقوي
وشديد واصبح هناك استهداف للمراه واستهداف
لحقوق المراه ولحقوق النساء بشكل بشع وشرس
الذي
نؤمن بها جميعا ان حركه الطالبان هي حركه
ارهابيه جماعه ارهابيه يجب ان تصنف في
جميع الدول في جميع دول العالم على انها
جماعه ارهابيه وجماعه مسلحه
وتختطف حقوق النساء وتختطف حقوق البشر
دائما
تيار من التيارات السلفيه
طبعا هذا الدعاء همم حتى تبيض صفحتها وحتى
تدعي وحتى تضع لديها شرعيه وحتى تصنع
مشروعيتها
في العالم العربي وفي العالم الاسلامي على
انها جماعه سلفيه هي ليست جماعه سلفيه هي
جماعه بعد همم هي الدين هي الدين هي تكوين
من مزيج من القاعد من منظومه القاعده
ومنظومه سيد قطب ومنظومه الاخوان المسلمين
فهي خليط من هذا وذاك وانما تحاول ان تدعي
انها من الجماعات السلفيه التي
تدافع عن الاسلام وتدافع عن العقيده طبعا
بطبيعه الحال هي ليست عقيداتها سلفيه هي
عقيده عقيده ما تريديه تنتمي الى تيار
عقائد
لا علاقه لها بالسلفيه لان السلفيه لم
ليست بهذا الشكل لا تمارس اداره اداره
شؤون الدول بهذه الطريقه وان حاولت وتحاول
وتستمر بالمحاوله ان تنضم الى التيار
السلفي همم وانما هي وانما حركت طالبان هي
جماعه هي جين مزيج من هذا وذاك طيب قاعده
والاخوان والى اخره ومؤمن نظريات سيد قطب
والاعلى المودودي والى اخره من هؤلاء
القاده الذين رسموا خطوط حركه همم او رسم
الطالبان خطها على همم اثاره انما انا
اتكلم حينما اتحدث عن عن عن تعليم مثلا
حرب طالبان على تعليم المراه او على ان
المراه تدخل القهوه الى او تمشي بالشارع
او ما الى هنالك هذه لا علاقه لها
بالافكار السلفيه ممتاز في الوقت ذاته
تقول طالبان بانها ملتزمه بحقوق المراه
انا اتحدث عن هذا الكلام عندما انقلبت على
همم حكومه اشرف غني قالت بانها ملتزمه
بحقوق المراه كما نصت عليها الشريعه
الاسلاميه همم اليوم بعد عام كامل من
انقلابه على السلطه في افغانستان عادت
لتمنع الفتيات من الدراسه كذلك ايضا
لتمنعهن من العمل برايك اليوم كل العالم
الاسلامي كل مؤسسات الدينيه همم في العالم
الاسلامي رفضت قرر الطالبان ادنتها ايضا
حتى همم كذلك وقالت واعتبرت انها تناقد
الشريعه الاسلاميه في اي شريعه هذه التي
اتت بها طالبا برايك سيد فهد
طوال الوقت وطوال التاريخ عبر التاريخ
هناك مشكله بين بعض التيارات الاسلاميه
والحركات الاسلاميه
ومعظم كل الحركات الاسلاميه وانما لا
اتحدث عن السلفيه السلفيه لديها موقف
مختلف من تعليم البنات حنا نتحدث مثلا عن
مسيره التعليم البنات في الخليج موضوع
مختلف لكن في في حركه طالبان منذ ان همم
اقبضت على مقاليد الحكم منذ ان تولت
مقاليد الحكم في افغانستان وهي تحاول ان
تجعل المراه درجه ادنى هذه مشكله هذه
مشكله لانها لا تؤسس لمستوى دوله مفهوم
الدوله يقوم على المساواه يقوم على
المساواه بين الرجل والمراه هي همم يعني
ضمن الاخبار اللي قراتها قراتها منعت همم
الفتيات من دخول المقاهي يعني المراه لا
تستطيع ان تدخل الكوفي شوب مثلا همم
تتناول القهوه همم همم ممكن تراجع دراسها
ممكن همم تكتب مقاله ممكن يعني هذا حق من
حقوقها الطبيعيه لم تستطع حركه طالبان ان
توفي بمواعدت به يعني حركه طالبان انا
اعتبرها يعني هي نسخه همم نسخه مدونه من
تنظيم القاعده يعني تنظيم القاعده لم يمسك
بدوله همم تلك الايام كان اسامه بن لادن
ماذا يقول كان يقول ان بيل كلينتون هو اخر
رئيس للولايات المتحده الامريكيه بمعنى
انه يقول انا انا رجل بلا دوله هو يريد ان
يمسك بتلابيب دوله لم يستطع نفسك من الذي
امسك بتلابيب الدوله هي حركه طالبان امسكت
بدوله وانما
وضعت كل افكار اسامه بن لادن وايمن
الظواهري
وضعتها في ضمن استراتيجيتها في الحكم
ولذلك الان
افغانستان تعاني من ازمه شرسه
اسمها
ازمه عدم عدم وجود مفهوم للدوله نعم هناك
مؤسسات معينه هناك جيش هناك سلطه هناك
شرطه الى اخره وانما مفهوم الدوله بمعناها
العميقه الفلسفه العميق غير موجود
انها تجلد تجد فتيات في الشارع
وتعاقب وتعاقب من يذهبنا الى المدرسه
وتعاقب من يذهبنا الى همم الى المقهى والى
اخره
اليوم نعم نعم وانما لا يوجد معك بهذا
السؤال اليوم تحت اي تصنيف ممكن ان تضع
مثلا من شارك في البدايه في وسم طالبان
تنتصر عندما
انقلبت على سلطه اشرف غني
استلمت زمام الامور والدوله في افغانستان
هنا كمان ايدها وقلبي انها حركه دينيه
منظمه بانها تغيرت حتى اصلا بعد هذه
القرارات لا زال هناك من يتبنى هذه
الافكار من يتمنى ايضا تصديرها هناك واحده
من موردات تقول شكرا لطالبات شكرا الحكومه
الطالبان وهي امراه والمراه مقتطفه حقوقها
اليوم في افغانستان همم
وهنا كان في برلمانات معينه وهناك يعني
المشكله ان احنا لا نقتنع بشكل كامل
المشكله فيه منظومه معين منظومه منظومه
حركيه معينه متشابهه ومترابطه لا تؤمن ان
حركه طالبان
جماعه ارهابيه مسلحه هذا الملف ابحث فيه
من اكثر من 20 سنه واعرف حركه طالبان
المشكله الوقت
لا يكفي لان نتحدث لاكثر من ما نتحدث فيها
الان هي جماعه هي منظومه مثل ما قلت لك هي
منظومه ارهابيه والذين يؤيدونها يؤيدونها
لانها مسكت بتلابيب الدوله فهم بمعنى ما
يدعون انهم يؤيدون دوله افغانستان
وبما فيها حركه طالبان وانما في عمقهم في
عمقهم الحقيقي يؤيدون حركه طالبان
ومنظومتها وايدي لوجيتها ايديولوجيه تركز
على هذه يناير ايديولوجيتها الفكريه نعم
وهذا خطر كبير جدا على الحكومات تنتبه
يعني مثلا تتحدث عن السعوديه وتحدث عن
الامارات وتحدث عن يعني مجموعه من الدول
امنتان همم حركه طالبا حركه ارهابيه جماعه
ارهابيه مسلحه طارق
الدنيا تطارد الدنيا
ضد الدنيا وضد حيويه الحياه وضد مفهوم
الدوله وهذا هو الاخطر يا استاذ نايف ضد
مفهوم مفهوم مفهوم الدوله نعم انا اشكرك
جزيل الشكر
على المشاركه معنا من دبي
شكرا لك
في جازان جنوب غرب السعوديه تتواصل
والاعمال الانشائيه في مطار الملك عبد
الله الدوليه الجديد حيث قربت نسبه
الانجاز في المشروع 45% من المقرر ايضا ان
يستوعب المطار الذي تبلغ مساحته نحو 50
مليون متر مربع نحو ثلاثه ملايين و600 الف
مسافر سنويا كما سيقلقوا فرصا استثماريه
بالاضافه لتحسين البنيه التحتيه لهذه
المنطقه كونه يتوسط مدينه جزان الاقتصاديه
من مشروع مطار الملك عبد الله بجازان
مراسل العربيه اسامه القاسم اسامه مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض تتواجد الان في هذا مشروع مشروع
المطار الجديد في جازان نسبه الانجاز وصلت
الى 45% لكن على الارض التي
اهلا وسهلا نايف تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع على
المشاهدين الكرام لقناه العربيه بالتاكيد
اليوم اقف الان بالضبط على كوبري المغادره
التي يؤدي الى مطار جازان الدولي الجديد
الذي تم ان يعني الانتهاء من الاعمال
الانشائيه بالنسبه ل 43% بالتمام هذه
النسبه بالتاكيد خلال عامين مضت بنسبه
كبيره جدا عدد من المشاريع عدد من المباني
كما تشاهدون الان ثم انشائها بالكامل على
مستوى البناء يستوعب المطار اكثر من ثلاثه
مليون و600 الف مسافر سنويا وهو ما يعتبر
ضعف العدد الموجود في المطار الحالي
المطار ايضا اكثر من ثلاثه الاف و500
موقف للمركبات هذا المطار ايضا يحتوي على
عدد من المقرات وايضا عدد من الاماكن التي
تقدم خدمه كبيره جدا للمسافرين هذا
المشروع ايضا وهذه نقطه مميزه الفريق
الانشائي والاداري هو فريق سعودي بالكامل
قام بانشاء هذا للمطار ومتوقعات كبيره جدا
بان خلال اعوام القادم حول العالم سنتين
القادمه ستم همم افتتاح المطار في حلتها
الجديده للحديث اكثر عن مطار جازان الدولي
الجديد سعود ان يكون معي الدكتور سالم
شعيب وهو مدير مشروع جازان الدولي الجديد
اهلا وسهلا فيك دكتور ابتداء ما نعرف نشره
الرابعه حدثنا اليوم عن ما هي الاعمال
الانشائيه التي تم الانتهاء منها اليوم في
مطار جازان الجديد مساء الخير عليكم اسامه
وعلى المشاهدين الكرام همم يعتبر المطار
واحد من اهم المشاريع الاستراتيجيه في
تطوير قطاع النقل الجوي كذلك المطار يعتبر
منطقه جازان
راعينا في تصميم المطار احدث الانظمه وهمم
التصاميم في مجال انشاء المطارات الدوليه
المطار انعكاس عكسنا بالتاكيد همم واقع
المنطقه التراثي والعمراني على التصاميم
الداخليه
والخارجيه للمطار نتوقع ان
يسهل المطار سفر ما يقارب
3,600,000 مسافر سنويا المطار يتكون من
تقريبا 39 مبنى لعل اهم مبنى في المطار هو
مبنى صاله السفر الرئيسيه واللي تحتوي على
12 بوابه للسفر عشر بوابات منها متحركه
تستطيع استيعاب 12 طائره في نفس التوقيت
بالاضافه الى ذلك همم برج المراقبه الجويه
بارتفاع 35 متر واللي تم الانتهاء من
تقريبا 76% من اعمال الخرسانه في البرج
ايضا احنا نتكلم اليوم على مدرج طائرات
رئيسي بطول 3,600 متر وعرض 60 متر كذلك
مدرج موازي لا ننسى الصاله الملكيه
بمساحه قدر ب 2,800 متر مربع تم الانتهاء
من تقريبا 40% من جميع اعمال الصاله
الملكيه بالاضافه الى 36 مبنى خدمات راح
تساهم في تشغيل المطار حال افتتاحه بحول
الله احنا المطار مربي انتهينا ولله الحمد
من المرحله الاولى من المطار واللي هي طيب
دكتور اليوم اريد ايضا ان اعرف الارقام
الموجوده اليوم هنا على المستوى الخرسانه
على مستوى ايضا قلبنا على مستوى التربه
ايضا انتم همم حفرتم امطار في الارض ايضا
ارتفاع ايضا مستوى المطار اليوم على مستوى
البحر حيث ان البحر ايضا قريب منه بقرابه
الثلاثه كيلو مترات تحدثنا عن هذه الارقام
دكتور بشكل موجز زي ما تعرف اسامه احنا
اليوم نقف في ارضيه همم التربه فيها ضعيفه
جدا احنا زرعنا لتدعيم ارضيه المطار ما
يقارب من
350,000 عمود همم حجري كذلك زرعنا ما
2800 ودد خراساني بعمق 32 متر لحمل
المباني الرئيسيه للمطار اليوم احنا نقف
على كوبري المغادره وكذلك احنا انتهينا
منه بنسبه
95% دكتور سالم وانت مدير مشروع المطار
جديد شكرا لك اذا اتحدث اليوم نايف من هنا
من هذا المطار مطار جازان الدولي الجديد
الذي يعتبر بالتاكيد بوابه كبيره جدا
الاستثمار للسياحه نضع لتوجه السعوديه
ايضا لاهتمام بالسياحه وايضا التجاره
خصوصا الاتفاقيه الصينيه الاخيره بما ان
ايضا الميناء الجديد ليس ببعيد ذلك البعد
الكبير عن مطار جازان شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك
وراس العربيه من جازان سمكه
رابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
موجه امطار على سواحل عمان والامارات
والموعد السنوي لثلوج تبوك يتجدد
حياكم الله شهدت عدد من المحافظات
العمانيه ومنها العاصمه مسقط وطول امطار
متفاوته الغزاله بدايه من صباح اليوم انت
لتعليق الدراسه في العاصمه تشير توقعات
مشاهدينا الى استمرار التاثر اجواء سلطنه
باخدود جوي حتى صباح الخميس المقبل
[تصفيق]
ومن عمان الى تبوك شمال غرب السعوديه التي
تضرب موعد سنويا مع الثلوج نشاهد هذه
الصور من تساقط الثلوج على جبال اللوز
[موسيقى]
ونبقى في شمال السعوديه ومن الحدود
الشماليه التي تشهد انخفاضا حاد في درجات
الحراره معنا من هناك مراسل العربيه هاني
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض
انت ايضا يا هاني كيف كانت الرحله اللي
وصلت فيها الى الحدود الشماليه التقلبات
الجويه والمناخيه ايضا
نعم نايف اهلا بك ولا بمشاهدين قناه
العربيه طبعا الكاميرا العربيه وفريق
العربيه كان يرصد ويطارد السحب ابتداء من
رفحه الواقعه في الحدود الشماليه وبعد ذلك
اتجهنا مباشره الى طريف مرورا ايضا بعرعر
وحزم الجلاميذ وكذلك القريات والان طبرجل
محافظه طبرجل وبعد قليل سوف نتجه الى تبوك
طبعا مجمل هذه المناطق وهذه المدن
والمحافظات كانت
تصف بصفه واحده وهي انخفاض في درجات
الحراره خاصه في ساعات الصباح الاولى
والتي وصلت الى ثلاث درجات فوق الصفر وكان
ال- ال- ال- الدرجه الحراره الكبرى همم لا
تتجاوز الثلاثه عشر درجه مئويه الان لعل
ان الفاظ هناك او هناك هناك انخفاض في
درجات الحراره الان في طبرجل في الموقع
الذي نتواجد فيه هنا درجه حراره التسع
الدراجات طبعا هناك استثناء خاص ايضا
بالنسبه لمنطقه تبوك شمال غرب السعوديه
والتي شهدت تساقطا
متوسطا في الثلوج والتي بلغت او بلغ درجه
الحراره فيها ووصلت فيها درجه الحراره الى
ثلاثه تحت الصفر خاصه في جبل اللوز وايضا
في منطقه نيوم التي شهدت تساقطا في الثلوج
ايضا بشكل كثيف وكما شاهدنا في الصور
الخاصه العربيه والتي رصدناها طبعا في هذه
الاجواء وفي هذه المنطقه والاوقات حاليا
نشاهد ايضا هناك يتكون للسحب الممطره ما
زالت الفورصه مهيئه طبعا ايضا المنطقه
الحدود الشماليه ما زالت ايضا تنعم
بالامطار ما بين متوسطه الى غزيره خاصه في
ساعه الصباح الاولى شهيده امطار متوسطه
وبعد ذلك ارتفعت همم وارتفعت كميه الامطار
الى وصلت الى الغزال ايضا خلال اليوم
وايضا الى يوم غد سوف تشهد امطار غزيره
نشاهد ايضا تكون السحب هنا في محافظه
طبرجل ولا يختلف الامر كثيره ايضا بالنسبه
لباقي المناطق في الحدود الشماليه سواء
القريات طريف رفحاء وكذلك عرعر ولعل عرعر
ورفحه هي الاقل همم كميه في الامطار حتى
هذه اللحظه طبعا عندما نتحدث عن كميه
الامطار وايضا الامطار التي هطلت في هذه
الاوقات لعلها انها سبقت عن الموعد المحدد
لها ايضا تساقط الثلوج في منطقه نيوم
وكذلك منطقه تبوك جاءت في وقتها وقبل
موعدها ب 20 يوم انه هو المعتاد دائما ان
تتساقط ثلوج في الخامس عشر والسابع عشر من
يناير من كل عام لكن هذا العام همم بدات
في ديسمبر ولع لها على استثنائيه مختلفه
تشدها منطقه نيون طبعا منطقه نيوم والتي
دائما ما هي معروفه بتضاريسها هو
جمالياتها ايضا هي دائما تشهد هذه كميه
ثلوج وكذلك موعود ايضا خلال الفتره
المقبله بكميه كبيره من الامطار
يعني ما شاء الله لابس على الاقل تحت
الصفر خمسه تحت الصفر ما راح تتاثر
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل رحله سعيده ان شاء الله من شمال
السعوديه الحدود الشماليه تحديدا مراسل
العربيه شكرا لك
التفاصيل في تقويم عقد الزواج
[موسيقى]
اشهر مواسم الشتاء
المربعانيه وسميت بذلك لام مدتها 40 يوما
وعرب الباديه يعتبرون المربعانيه بدايه
البرد في اول ديسمبر وحرب الشام يعتبرون
المربعانيه شده البرد في 23 ديسمبر اي
بالمنقلب الشتوي ويستدلون على ذلك باطول
ظل زوالي في السنه بين قوسين الطنطوره
فالخلاف بين هذا وذاك 20 يوما تقريبا
والخلاف بينهم اختلاف تنوع ليس اختلاف
كذله من اللي توده فكر بحفظ الود وابعد عن
الرد حبل المواصل بين الاقارب مده اذا شده
واذا
شد
[موسيقى]
واذا تمكنت قبضه المربعانيه من عناصر
المنظومه المناخيه يشتد عصفريحه شماليه
البارده وبانتهائها يشتد عصف الريح
الماكره التي لا تستقر على جهه معينه فبرد
المربعانيه في باطنها وفي ظاهرها وبرد
الشوبط في ظهرها وشباط
[موسيقى]
نختم بالعناوين
اسرائيل تحضر العالم صنع القرار سيتغير
عالميا اذا امتلكت ايران سلاح نوويه
دعاه التطرف الى الواجهه مجددا متطرفون في
المنطقه يعلنون قرار طالبان لمنع تدريس
الفتيات
يومين تفصل احياء الرياضه عن رحله التشجير
اكثر من سبعه ملايين شجره ضمن مشروع
الرياض الخضراء
والجهاز 45% من اعمال مطار جازان الجديد
طاقه استيعابيه تتجاوز ثلاثه ملايين مسافر
سنويا
موجه امطار على سواحل عمان والامارات
والموعد السنوي لثلوج تبوك يتجدد
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]